good to see you playing well with others
again just like a bad I dig it may be
temporary I'm just starting but I will
say that one of the reasons I was drawn
to it is I had a similar fascination to
Batman when I was young that I had with
the the ape series which I was obsessed
with and I see a parallel emotionally
between Caesar and Batman in that
they're both characters who are tortured
and trying to sort of grapple with their
within themselves to find the way to do
the right thing in a very imperfect and
to some degree corrupt world and so it's
really that emotionality that I'm
interested in I want to do a very
point-of-view driven you know this this
film and all of the times what I try to
do in an almost Hitchcockian sense is
use the camera and use the storytelling
so that you become the character and you
empathize at that point of view and I
think there's a chance to do an almost
Noir driven detective version of Batman
that is point-of-view driven in a very
very powerful way that hopefully is
going to connect you to what's going on
inside of his head and inside of his
heart the shroud of secrecy around these
movies but you're going into the DC
Universe well yeah that man yes and I
was a huge Batman fan and I had actually
the same there were these dolls when I
was a kid by Mego I was captivated by by
him and and him as a character and just
I had all the toys I had the Batmobile
from I don't know if it was dinky or
Corgi but this amazing old cars and that
kind of stuff and I think I think what's
interesting to me is that you know right
now Hollywood is making a very narrow
band of movies right everything is about
a franchise about a pre-existing
property and that very highly personal
point of view driven mode what I see in
Batman that I find so interesting is
that in a way he reminds me of Caesar in
that he is a character with a really
troubled past who is grappling with in
himself to try and find the way to do
the right thing in a really imperfect
world in a corrupt world and I find that
that provides an opportunity again if
you want to take that
when you use storytelling and I could
imagine the stories being like a noir
you know like heavily point-of-view
driven I mean the originals were from
the Golden Age were they were detective
stories right we really like this yeah
exactly and I think that if you can
marry that with the personal that
there's a chance to do something very
exciting so again I see an opportunity
to do something that might be hard to do
in another way in the studio system and
if you're going to make a movie in the
studio system I find that this kind of
filmmaking can be very exciting yeah
okay do you have favorite Batman story
arcs sure yeah I do
but I think well also i wouldnt want to
get into that now because if i do then
in every speculation that we're just
doing that story share but i can tell
you this that you know we are looking to
all of those and i'm also looking to
other ways that it feels personal like
to me like I said the thing that's
interesting is the ways in which you can
connect to these stories but it's what
the what the genre is a cover for well
how it relates to the world that we're
in and so I think you know I'm going to
draw inspiration from those stories but
I want it to be something that's rooted
in something that feels not only
personal to be a bit relevant you know
to the time so you know there were the
reports that negotiations broke down at
some point you guys came back to the
table obviously and made a deal what
that leaves me curious about is how
confident you feel like you can go in
there and do the story you want to do at
DC I certainly hope so I mean they you
know let's put it this way they I've
never worked with them but my experience
with them so far has been really good
and as I describe what I want to do they
seem really excited everybody you guys
have been asking for new Justice League
Batman that was the director of the
Batman movie so they're getting ready to
go into production I'll explain what he
meant when he was teasing all that stuff
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so when he talks about
Hitchcockian noir driven detective
thriller he's just talking about the
Mord war Batman stories they dropped all
kinds of references to things like long
Halloween I think they'll take
inspiration from stuff like hush there
was scott Snyder's first run which is
called black mirror that was actually a
Dick Grayson as Batman Ark when he was
still wearing the costume after
everybody thought that bat
he's secretly gotten sent back in time
but the story is really good
there's Grant Morrison's Batman he wrote
this really awesome run called gothic
which is inspired by Fritz Lang's and
which is one of the best noir movies of
all time really anything from that pile
hush is at the top of my list just
because it features all of Batman's
biggest villains but it's still very
Hitchcockian in that it's first-person
you're following Batman's perspective
the whole time so when Matt Reeves is
talking about Hitchcock when he
explained the Batman film most of what
he's talking about is the way they use
the camera like literally the way the
camera moves in the perspectives that it
takes as well as the way you follow the
character around so like Batman be a
Superman you have a couple different
perspectives you jump to Superman's
perspective then you jump back to Batman
you even get a little bit of Wonder
Woman I don't really consider
Christopher Nolan's trilogy noir films
just because there's so much daylight
during that and literally noir means
black so more films typically take place
at night there's long shadows that's why
I included so much of that long
Halloween when they're talking about
comic book inspiration look at these
panels in the way the light spills on
the page the way it spills on the
characters faces those are stylistic
things that you see in noir films so
expect stuff like that in the Batman
movie which is perfect for the character
so beyond that the only thing we know is
that they're populating his universe
with more of his rogues gallery you have
the Gotham City sirens movie so we'll
already have poison ivy we'll have the
Selina Kyle Catwoman and then obviously
you have Harley Quinn and all the other
characters that they've already surfaced
so far so I wouldn't expect it to move
around geographically as much as
Christopher Nolan's movies did like
during Dark Knight great film they go
all over the place it's not just setting
Gotham I'm really expecting them to use
the first new Ben Affleck solo Batman
movie to really show you what this
version of Gotham looks like you've
gotten a little bit of it during Batman
V Superman you watching cleaning out the
slums you see him in Suicide Squad going
after the Joker and Harley Quinn but you
really only see brief street shots you
don't really get to revel in that Gothic
architecture in so much of Gotham's
identity is tied up in its architecture
so that's one of the most fun things
about revisiting the old Batman movies
is seeing the way they treated that Tim
Burton did a great job with that
Christopher no
Gotham looks a lot more like Chicago
because they filmed it in Chicago but I
love the way that he addresses the
studio issues that he had like for a
little while he wasn't doing the movie
then the deal was back on that's just
part of the process of him getting a
little bit more control over the film so
he was originally going to come in and
it sounds like they were going to go
with the previous version of the script
but now he has a producer credits will
have a little more authorship originally
Jeff Johnson Ben Affleck wrote a draft
of the script it'll be really
interesting to see how much of that
version of the movie makes it into the
final cut because it sounds like they're
going to switch some of the characters
Deathstroke is still a big question mark
whether or not he's still going to be in
Matt Reeves version it sounds like he
will but the interesting thing is he's
not a real big Gotham character so it'll
be interesting to see how they bring him
to Gotham City but in the meantime if
you do want to reread some of the comics
I would recommend hush it's just a great
story overall but it's also very
relevant to this Justice League DC EU
Batman movie and of course long
Halloween and I know I included a little
bit of the button in there I don't think
there's any chance that they'd do
something like that it would be crazy if
they try to tie the Watchmen to the DCE
you that's something that they might try
ten years down the road if they really
want to get nuts with it believe all
your requests for DC movie videos in the
comments below they'll be a little bit
more as they start to promote Justice
League we're going to be doing a whole
bunch of stuff around Comic Con so
obviously I'll remind everybody when
they get started they haven't announced
their plans but they'll be promoting
Justice League mostly as well as the
Aquaman movie but what's happening next
is I have some new Marvel DC that I'm
going to post tomorrow congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner King ruff
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for brand new flash episode 1 and you
can click here for my spider-man
homecoming review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you